the guys were here at the Sundance Film
Festival with your new movie whiplash
now where did the inspiration come from
Damian for it I am a drummer myself and
I went through an experience not too
dissimilar to what's in the movie and at
certain point I was just you know it
seemed like something I wanted to write
about it I was searching for something
to write and it was actually one to be
in the most personal fastest thing I'd
ever written it just kind of came out
and certainly the making of it was
pretty fast as well
you had 19 days that's pretty speeding
isn't it now Austin you're in the movie
you play one of the young guys at the
music school and you're a drummer now
what was it like preparing for the role
do you play the drums yourself I didn't
play the drums
Damian took a shot on me but I had about
a month to get ready and so I would play
just everywhere I went I would bring
drum sticks I was playing at my car and
on my mattress and on my dog and
wherever he really liked it I guess some
people would think he want it kind of
don't know their music that being a
terma would be like the easy part of
being in a band or a degree for it okay
so when they kick you know it's not the
notes that kind of stuff I'm sure that
you've had that from people as well
Irene so what do you say for them to say
hey Matt it's actually really hard I
mean there's literally blood sweat and
tears in this book that in a way where
you say is actually part of what makes
it hard because in in this sort of sort
of environment that the movie depicts
drummers are in a way treated the most
harshly because it's it's there's almost
these sort of jokes if there's the
musicians and then there's the drummers
and like what the hell is wrong you
can't keep my tempo that's all you need
to do keep my tempo and and so there's a
way in which drummers are really
isolated you stick out like a sore thumb
in a way that you don't if you're a part
of five saxes and so it's the most in a
way if you're playing badly on the drums
it's the most humiliating instrument to
be playing out that loud don't you like
everyone can hear you're the one keeping
you can't hide yeah there's a whole
Orchestra sometimes and there's one
drummer yeah that's what always shocks
me is that it's all on one person now
how much were you into jazz before you
went into this movie
I love jazz actually I Drive around
that's what keeps me calm in LA traffic
I know I go to the jazz station there's
a great it's 88 one I think I and I love
that station it calms me down and puts
me at a good mood I love jazz because
it's it's it's very it's very visceral
you know it's just this thing that you
want to that you feel it you really feel
jazz so I I love jazz
how is it playing that kind of rivalry
with Miles Tellez character as well in
the film because you do have that going
on Dania it's not so much a rivalry to
Ryan because he's there because he loves
music you know that it's really not
about the competition he doesn't see it
that way if it works out for him great
if it doesn't hey good for the other guy
that he's actually not the you know he's
not the typical jock jerk who is kind of
good at everything you know yes he
probably is naturally gifted at things
and you know it doesn't work as much as
Andrew does but that also doesn't he
doesn't take advantage of that you just
kind of all right this is cool I'm I'm
gonna play in the drums and it makes me
feel good so I'm gonna keep doing it any
of you had in your own lives that
character like JK Simmons character it
was such a hard-ass isn't he when he
pushes those guys to the edge yeah I had
a conductor who didn't go to the
extremes that JK went but the character
in the movie sort of a mesh of my
conductor and then conductors of
musicians I know well actually went to
Juilliard and music schools like that in
my case was more of a high school
program and then also just people
throughout history like Buddy Rich Miles
Davis I mean we even have recordings of
Buddy Rich directing his band that
there's just a wealth of inspiration for
if you want to write a character like
that in the jazz world you have so many
places to just pull from there's nothing
that he does in the movie that's you
know that that is out of character for
for what these types of people can be
like I mean how much did JK freak you
out when he was kind of really
into the park there wasn't much acting
going on in those scenes for me he comes
at you he's terrifying
he's absolutely terrifying and and it's
so fun it's amazing his ability to
switch right when they call cut he
starts joking around and he's a
wonderful guy but yeah he's he's intense
to say and it's all in his eyes man yeah
he he look like the devil himself when
it when he's at the JBC concert and you
know that he's just you know with that
backlit and
man it was such a powerful moment so
yeah kudos to JK and finally what's up
for you guys next what we look forward
to from each of you I'm not sure I mean
I have certain things I want to do but
uh trying to keep my options open at the
moment I've been in the hole with this
movie for a while the schedule was so
tight that we literally you know barely
had time to breathe let alone think of
other projects probably so now I'm kind
of emerging back into the world a little
bit it'll actually be nice to get back
to reality in a weird way I've got four
films coming out this year and shooting
down in Florida right now so trying to
stay busy a little bit about those films
and what you're doing at the moment
right now I'm shooting the sequel to
Dolphin Tale which was Warner Brothers
film and Alcon but and then the films
that are coming out there's another
independent called Warren that I'm
actually going to the Santa Barbara Film
Festival next week where it premieres
and another film with Selena Gomez where
I play her boyfriend in that and that
one I'm a total jerk I say some of the
most vile things in the world it was a
lot of fun and my mother came to set on
one of the days where it was just
absolute welcome to our lives real
stressful environment did you get into
your big drum solo yeah it was though
did you nail that what I'm lucky enough
to I'm not a method actor and so we were
all and neither is Miles and so we were
able to to hang out and clown around and
then when it was time to get into it
make that switch guys it's a lovely
talking to you really it's a fantastic
film well done and I hope it does really
well whew both thanks
you